el Chase bonjour Emmanuel frappe russe
meurtrière à vivre je le disais et le
bilan lui semble s'alourdir de ranmer
bonjour oui tout à fait les secours sont
encore sur place si on a des images
notamment des images aériennes qui
montrent l'ampleur de la destruction
suivant ses frappes et bien on voit
qu'il y a qu'effectivement il y a des
dommages
extrêmement conséquents il y a 37
personnes blessées pour le moment ce
bilan pourrait s'agourdir très entre
elles sont à l'hôpital avec des degrés
de blessures variées parmi les quatre
victimes la plus jeune à 21 ans il
s'agit d'une jeune femme Anastasia qui
était employée à la poste
ukrainienne la plus âgée de ces quatre
victimes à 95 ans c'était une femme qui
avait donc survécu à la deuxième guerre
mondiale et puis finalement a eu cette
fin de vie absolument atroce une frappe
de missiles de type calibre il y en a
trois qui se sont abattus sur lui cette
nuit et qui est venue ruiner la vie de
dizaines de personnes les dommages
matériels sont également immenses il y a
il y a plus de 60 appartements qui ont
été détruits plus de 30 bâtiments qui
ont été endommagés une cinquantaine de
voitures ça montre l'échelle de
destruction de ces frappes des frappes
qui sont quotidiennes alors c'est vrai
que le vif à l'ouest du pays et
seulement environ 120 km de la frontière
avec la Pologne et donc avec l'Union
européenne c'est vrai que cette ville
est rarement frappée mais cette frappe
là et bien c'est la frappe la plus
importante contre contre cette ville le
maire de la ville sadovi a d'ailleurs
décrété deux jours de deuil dans sa
ville après cette attaque merci beaucoup
Emmanuel pour toutes ces explications
Emmanuel